a familiar matchup
for a pair of american league foes who
have been here
in the postseason before in fact this
indians yankees matchup
is the only one of the wild card series
matchups where the two
teams have played one another in the
fall previously right-hander shane
bieber
25 year old who put up a season for the
ages claiming a rare
pitching triple crown the first in
baseball since johan santana did it back
in 2006. led the league in wins
a share of that title with you darvish
of the cubs led the league in era
and led all the baseball with 122
strikeouts a dream season for shane
bieber
and a chance to continue it tonight lead
offender report for the two-time
all-star right fielder aaron judge
judge on the first pitch sends a ball
well hit out to right center field on
the run is to shields and it's gone
two nothing yankees four pitches into
the ball game
it's a quick yankee strike a tall order
tonight
against the 30 year old three-time
all-star yankee ace garrett cole
who last worked on tuesday seven strong
innings
cole finished the season in terrific
shape the first four hitters are switch
hitters
and they could put the ball in play the
strikeout starts the night for garrett
cole
two and two by the way to cesar
hernandez
back-to-back strikeouts open the ball
game for garrett cole
this is power pitching and that's what
garrett cole has been doing as of late
look at the life
98 miles an hour top of the zone
falling two strikes to count to
higashioka and he gets them swinging
there was one
the big curveball takes care of
higashiyoka
for his second strike out of it still a
full count to santana
another one that's chased up in the
strike zone third strike out of the game
for cole
and reyes is behind the ball in two
strikes pitchers on that roster
as reyes chases a breaking ball four
strikeouts for cold already tonight
64 of his two-strike counts result in a
punch out
he got one here finally made le mayhew
expand the strike zone
luke voight grounded out in a sharply
hit ball to third in his first try
tonight
three balls in a strike devoid with two
out and a man aboard
pitcher catches a lot of the strike zone
that's headed for the gap in left center
field
hicks is being waved around
throw to the plate will be too late and
it's three-nothing new york
and too good of a season too hot seeing
the ball too well with too much
confidence
garrett cole has struck out four through
two innings
big breaking ball swung out and missed
one gone to start the third
two runners on two away for their best
run
producer and that's a
fair ball into the corner
it scores de shields and puts the
indians on the board in the third
fastball in short and tight and ramirez
continues
his sizzling hitting for the indians
santana behind 0-2
and he gets him with the gas his firmest
velocity of the night at 99
miles an hour a run in but two left
stranded at the end of three
so one out and one on now back to brett
gardner who reached on a fielder's
choice back in the second
first pitch fastball sent out to left
center field and off the track and wall
bare handed by naylor torres coming
around
he'll score and it's a 4-1 new york lead
virtually all the damage tonight alex on
first pitch fastballs
le mayhew has singled and struck out
tonight
at what point the bullpen steps up great
play by
lindor throw to first is not in time
however
another run scores it's five to one
yankees
and good wheels here by lamehu getting
down the line for the rbi single
one gun base is empty for josh naylor
he also has a home run against garrett
cole tonight
well josh naylor isn't having any
trouble with cole that's for sure
adding a homer to his double line 5-2
yankee lead throughout base runner now
for gleber torres
the next 2-2 another fastball and that's
hit in the air out to deep left field
naylor giving chase as is to shields and
that one's gone
the second two-run homer of the night
for new york
and they've extended their lead at 7-2
yankees two quick outs for garrett cole
that'll bring back
cesar hernandez who's got a single
tonight
[Applause]
ten strikeouts for garrett cole tonight
a part of a one two three bottom of the
fence
and he's just struck out his 11th batter
of the night
a dominant night for garrett a third
weapon for that guy to add to the 98
mile an hour fastball
on the slider geo rochelle sends a fly
ball out to right
naked camping under it anticipating a
play hicks will tag up
the throw home is too late and it's 8-2
new york
so here's labor torres now who has
singled and hit a two-run home run
doesn't count 0-0 stats at this point
and he adds another rbi knock to an
already big night
nine to two yankees rookie right-hander
cam hill takes over here with two gone
in the seventh doing postseason games
from different series in the same day
it's a new one for us
brett gardner adds to the damage with a
two-run homer
and this one has turned into a route
full count three balls and two strikes
to roberto perez
and he gets him number 12 for coal
tonight
we've got tyler glass now to try to
finish it off tomorrow
and a called strike three that's 13
for garrett cole tonight here's stanton
now with one gun
oh that could be the start of something
the big fella gets a hold of one and
has a solo homer here in the ninth
adding to the damage 12 to two yankees
and cleveland's down to their final out
of the game
tap her out the shortstop that's going
to wrap it up
all yankees in cleveland tonight are
rather lopsided game one win
four home runs at dominant garrett cole
and everything going to plan
for aaron boone and the yankees